when I tried it I felt better than ever
head so I just kept on doing it
why no I thought we were closer than
most fathers and sons this isn't us this
is not who we have you stop there are
moments that I look at him and I wonder
who is how's that boy David I'm not
giving up now
never
[Music]
you always gotta be controlling
everything doesn't make any sense you
control me right now let us help you I
don't want you tell don't you understand
that I had such grand plans you'd
graduate from college do something
amazing and now I just wanted to not die
who are you Nick this isn't me that here
this is Who I am
if you could take all the words in the
language it's still in describing each
other I love you more than everything
I'm really sorry it's hard as hell to
get sober but I love my family I want to
be proud of me
[Music]
I understand how scared you are little
past though always does
Mack what you have is extraordinary
and you're gonna get it back you're
gonna find it together
[Music]